hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
sadiq khan has very recently
been re-elected as the mayor of london
now in this video i'm going to be
talking about how this is going to
affect you
as a property investor or potential
property investor
now i did predict that sadiq was
probably going to be re-elected
uh so it's no surprise but i've
researched heavily
into what i think the repercussions of
this are going to be
for landlords not just in london but
across the whole of the uk
because we know that everywhere follows
london so if something happens in london
it will usually ripple out and affect
other areas as well so take heeds if you
are a property investor
take notes and of course form your own
opinion everything i'm saying in
this video is just my opinion and
one of the things that happened to dick
actually he didn't win by massive uh he
got
55.2 votes so he did win comfortably
followed by sean bailey from
conservative party he got 44.8
so it's pretty good run you know pretty
good run but um something that sadiq
said that i think is very interesting
and i would agree with
is he said that he is concerned about
the
increasing dividedness
between us not just in london but across
the country
and i do agree with him on that point
that it does seem to be
a bigger and bigger a wider divide
between the rich and poor the left and
right between
um you know labor and and conservative
people all
assume i'm conservative people oh he's a
toy he's a tory i'm not necessarily
anything i'll vote depending on what the
policies are
at the time and i don't disagree with
everything that sadiq
does or says i had a debate with hakeem
who was a um an elected um
official for labour party and i said
look i'm not
saying i want sadiq to fail in fact if
sadiq gets in i want him to win
i want him to win i want all our leaders
to win because if their agenda is to
make the country better which it should
be then wanting them to fail is like
wanting the pilot of your plane to crash
it's nuts so you know that's kind of
generally my
my thought process so in this video i
want to talk about the good the bad and
the ugly
of sadiq's policies and how they're
going to affect
property investors or people wanting to
step into the property market
really important point as well is i
believe that the reason there's a big
divide
it's in politics but not just in
politics just generally is because
if someone says something and you don't
agree with them
back in the day what would you do you
debate with them like
let's have a conversation let's have a
discussion now if someone says something
you don't like like
you you block them you troll them you
hate them you alienate them and that's
why there's a bigger divide
so i'm really pro debating
i think if you agree on stuff the stuff
that i agree with to decon we're going
to talk about the good the bad and the
ugly the stuff that we agree on
let's stand together let's work together
and the stuff that we disagree on
let's have healthy debates because when
you have a healthy debate what you'll
normally find is
you don't disagree on the end solution
you disagree on the means to get there
when i had my debate with hakeem
we both agreed that we wanted more
affordable houses in london
we agreed that we want people to be at
peace and we want people to be free
and we want people to be happy of course
but it's about how do we get there so
people argue and
kill each other and hate each other
over just the road to get there because
they disagree on the route and i think
that is
madness so let's let's start by looking
at the things i agree with siddiquan and
the things that i think
are working really well so number one
the good stuff is he is providing
loans to developers for affordable
accommodation that is fantastic because
that's going to mean that we're going to
have more houses
so i agree with siddique on that he's
also providing funding for the
for rough sleepers which is again
absolutely fantastic
he's also put a list together of all the
rogue
landlords in london who are operating
illegally
boom good i'm glad that he's done that i
think it's important that
property investors have a high standard
he's campaigning
aggressively for blocks of flats to be
safe and to have fire safety and
he's trying to stop ground rents the
queen's speech on tuesday confirmed that
some of these plans
are going to come into fruition so good
i can stand with him on that these are
sensible policies
um the bad so siddique is talking about
this um
stand up for renters movement this
campaign about let's stand up for
renters
now that sounds fine i don't disagree
with standing up for renters but the the
ways that he's going about it i disagree
with
so a big part of the standing up for
renters is number one four months notice
minimum so if you want to evict a tenant
forever you're gonna get four months
okay but but it gets worse than that
he's trying to
ban completely ban what he calls
no fault evictions now no fault eviction
is when you evict somebody because you
want your house back you want to sell
the house
i've had a tenant living in there for
two years but now i want to sell it and
get my money and i want to retire you
can't
because you can't evict the tenant
unless they've done something wrong i'm
sorry that is a
stupid philosophy a crazy policy and
what will happen the reason i disagree
with these policies
is that landlords will have a house
maybe a tenant will move out and i think
you know what i don't want to sell the
house
um right this second but i think i might
want to sell it soon but i'm not
prepared to rent it now
because if i rent it i could have
someone move in there for 30 years
and i'm stuffed i can't even get rid of
them so
i think i'll just keep it empty for the
time being
investor from china india america
dubai a lot of these guys own
houses in london and it will just make
me think i don't want to even rent it
i'll just keep it empty for a bit that's
what they'll do and what's that going to
do it's going to be those of empty
houses
across london empty flats which is going
to mean there's less accommodation
it doesn't make sense it sounds
fantastic let's stand up for renters
but it is just flaws and this needs to
be debated
says there's overwhelming arguments for
some of these points but i haven't heard
the arguments
it just sounds to me like claptrap to
try and get votes
to try and be popular and potentially in
three years time when he finishes as
mayor of london to then just leave a big
mess
the country in a big mess but hey he was
popular for the three years that he was
honestly it really doesn't make sense so
that's the bad
i'm against that stuff so some good or
some bad what's the ugly
the ugly is rent control
now i've talked about this before i've
done a video about this before
i've debated hakeem before on this point
and
a rent control is something that really
bothers me and i've talked i'm gonna i'm
probably gonna do an in-depth
video about this if sadiq starts pushing
and i think it's actually gonna happen
part of me thinks that he was just
talking he's been talking about rent
control
to get votes but he has no intention of
actually trying to bring it in but i
i do get worried because if he caps
rents in london
it's it's gonna really mess up the
economy developers right now
are desperate to go into london and
start converting some of the rundown
commercial properties or the empty
commercial properties of which there's
loads you walk down london streets
what's it filled with
empty offices what are those empty
offices saying they're saying
convert me convert me to a residential
home we need more homes in london
that's a good thing and then siddiq
saying actually i might put rent caps in
place
rent control already developers now
going
and they're not wanting to come in and
restore these buildings and convert
these properties into homes
because of the idea of potential rent
control that is going to devastate
london and it's never worked it's ruined
everywhere it's touched
berlin new york los angeles
scotland scotland have even said
themselves it's been a flop it's been a
disaster
the scottish government have said that
when they brought it in just a few years
back berlin brought it in a year ago has
it helped
with rents no they've never gotten 50
shortage of houses as a part of that as
a result so i'm serving into rent
control
and if i if i see him like if i think
siddique is
serious we'll find out soon if i think
he's serious
i will potentially i don't know what i'm
going to do
i need your help let's start a petition
let's do something because because it
can't happen in london
it really really can't happen in london
um so that's my thoughts that's the good
the bad and the ugly i stand with
siddique
sodhik i don't know if you're watching
this but if you are congratulations for
getting reelected
um i hope you take this video and i hope
you listen to it and i hope you really
think about it
and i think as a people of london you
know sometimes the peop
the people that have the loudest voices
um
i'm not the majority and it's important
that we sometimes as the majority the
critical thinkers the people that can
see the effects he's had on every other
country
um actually speak out sometimes so those
are my thoughts
i spend a lot of time researching this
stuff not only for myself but also to
tell you what's happening so if you
appreciate me putting my content
together
please do me a favor let me know in the
comments and also smash the like button
and of course subscribe
i'll be doing future videos every single
day i do a video thanks for watching
peace out